hello there Steve Kaufman here again
talking about language learning what
else um I had a post on crashing stephen
krashen and talked a bit about it he is
the language learning expert who has
made popular the idea that the most
important thing in language learning is
to have access to meaningful content he
is very much behind reading extensive
reading silent reading he suggests that
children in class just be encouraged to
read rather than having to listen to a
teacher provide instruction to them uh
he also is in favor of listening I
posted on my blog reference to a website
by Benny Co Mason who is also has a
number of research studies there which
show that really reading by itself is
more effective than reading and
instruction in other words they took
however many students and they gave them
150 hours of reading I believe and one
group got an additional hundred and
fifty hours of writing practice and at
the end of the period those people who
only had reading did just as well as
those people had the who had the
additional writing practice and and it
goes on and on and the gist is that
really all you need to do is read and
listen but that the content should be
always obviously of interest to you and
constantly graded to your level just a
little bit more difficult just a little
bit difficult for you and not too
difficult so I mean I think that this is
largely true but I have some
reservations first of all I think it's
very important that what I'm reading and
I'm going to go based on my own
experience as a language learner I feel
that the interest in the subject is a
bigger factor than how difficult it is
so while it's nice to have something
that is just at that next level of
difficulty it would take a long time to
and pop two really interesting content
if I were constantly sort of reading and
listening to things that are
deliberately easy and and you know
graded readers and and I don't know
children's stories and so forth
so yes inevitably at the beginning to
some extent you need content largely
content which has fewer words that you
don't know and of course that's why it
link we tell you how many unknown words
there are for you in each bit of content
so that the more you use the system the
more accurate you can be in finding
stuff that is doesn't have too many new
words but it's impossible to have it so
perfectly graduated and and I think I
felt in learning Russian that I was very
motivated to try some Tolstoy and I
didn't want to read the silly little
stories about my friend from Germany
visited me in Leningrad and we visited
this park in that park and I had no
interest in it even though it had fewer
unknown words so at least in my case I'm
prepared to take on content with more
unknown words and I do believe that a
system like link makes it possible to
take on more difficult content you can
accelerate the process and get yourself
to genuine content faster so that is the
first place where I disagree with
crashing and Ben eco Mason and I happen
to believe that link provides a link a
bridge that gets you from the easy
content that you have to begin with up
to authentic content more unpredictable
vocabulary it gets you there faster so
that's the first place where I disagree
the second place where I disagree is
that I know that when I write if I'm
writing in Portuguese and I spell
something wrong and I see it I dumb bang
was a ta n mbem or you know it's not
really clear does it have an accent I
can't remember I look it up next time I
read I really notice that word I notice
it so there is no question in my mind
that some degree of output
is beneficial it helps you notice you
learn from your input but writing or
speaking helps you notice I don't think
you need to do a lot of it the problem
is that when you are starting out in the
language you can't speak very well so
it's stressful and it's no fun to talk a
lot with people it's the same with
writing you don't have to write a lot
but it just helps to kind of stimulate
massage your brain and it starts to make
you a little bit more observant at least
that's my own experience so some degree
of speaking and writing I think is
useful the other problem with speaking
especially with writing is it takes long
when you don't when you aren't very good
at the language whereas listening you
can hear a lot of the language you can
be training the brain just almost
passively listening to lots and lots of
the language in an hour of listening you
get an hour of native speaker content
thrown at you if you spend an hour
trying to write something I mean you
haven't that's an hour you haven't spent
listening
so some writing some listening as a
stimulus to the brain but not too much
of it the other thing I would say about
speaking is in order to end up being
genuinely fluent in the language you do
have to speak you have to eventually be
put in a situation where you have to
speak a lot so I feel now with my Russia
that I have built up my capability over
three years of lots of listening reading
overwhelmingly listening and reading a
little bit of writing and speaking once
a week twice a week maybe but in order
to really become fluent in the language
I would like to be somewhere where for a
month or two I have to speak Russian
every day and so that being put in that
situation but only when you have the
weapons to defend yourself only after a
lengthy period through largely through
input reading and listening then to go
out there and defend yourself that's
kind of where you finish yourself finish
off your your your ability and it is
true as Crowson points out that you can
be surrounded by the language and if
it's too early you can't take advantage
of it and you kind of close in and you
don't really notice anything if you can
ramp up through the impact input
activities then you can take advantage
of that total immersion
situation so I guess in summary and I
know there are some radical crashing
heights out there
fundamentally I think they are right
that the task of language learning and
language teaching has been made
totally totally unnecessarily
complicated and there are literally
billions of dollars being spent on
conventional language teaching most of
which is unnecessary that if we could
put that effort into finding ways to
induce people to listen and read and
maybe you have to test them in some way
or adlink we we measure the number of
links created we measure different ways
to make sure that in fact they are
reading and listening you can even ask
them questions but don't give them too
much writing
just a little enough to know that
they've been reading um enough to jog
the mind a little bit to make the mind a
little more observant but most they just
let them read and listen I think
listening is more powerful than reading
in terms of making the brain used to the
language I think the reading is
necessary for vocabulary accumulation
again particularly the way we do it at
link so I we could save a lot of time
and money we can have a lot more people
fluent in different languages if people
would try to understand what crashing
and been equal Mason have said but still
leaving a small role for vocabulary
review like the flashcards that we have
at link and a small amount of talking
and reading and I should add even though
I constantly say I can't understand
grammar explanations the key as I've
mentioned before get the smallest
grammar book you can find or find some
websites on the web quickly review if I
were going to take you know check or
finish roughly how does that line how is
it structured read it forget it and then
after a few months of listening and
reading have another flip through and I
think that also helps to make you more
attentive and observant so I am a crash
but with reservations and most of those
reservations and most of the ways in
which I think we can do a better job
than just plain reading and listening
are in fact included in what we have
built into link so again I'm going to
get roundly criticised by my friend Igor
of Macedonia for sort of always
promoting link but hey that's my
commitment that's what I'm trying to do
in order to help people learn more
languages and the vast majority people
who linghu use link use it free of
charge so but there again my views on
fashion I look forward to the criticism
bye for now